[موسيقى]
ست عادات ستغير حياتك للافضل لو اقلعت
عنها اولا الاستيقاظ مبكرا في موعد محدد
فعدم التزام في ذلك يوميا يضر بانتاجات
الشخص والنوم لمزيد من الدقائق قد يؤثر
على شعورك بالراحه والنشاط ثانيا
تجنب تعدد المهام مخصص وقتا لكل مهمه فان
انجاز عده مهام معا قد يشعرك بالرضا لكن
العقل قد يصاب بالتوتر ويفقد انتاجيته
ثالثا عدم تاجيل المهام حتى اللحظه
الاخيره فذلك يؤدي الى صعوبه انتاج بعضها
قسم المهام الكبيره الى خطوات قصيره رابعا
عدم تفضيل مصالح الاخرين هناك خيط رفيع
يفصل بين ان يكون الشخص لطيفا او سهل
المنال فمحاوله التواجد مع الجميع سيستنزف
وقتك وقدرتك على تلبيه احتياجاتك الشخصيه
خامسا اهمال الرعايه الذاتيه فالحماس
والرغبه في سرعه الانجاز ينبغي ان لا تتم
على حساب صحتك الجسديه والعقليه اخيرا
الرضا وعدم المقارنه بالاخر لان كل شخص
مسار مختلف فان لم تصادف النجاح فقط
الموقف كعبره ودرس وخبره عمليه على كل حال
سالنا الناس بالعراق ما هي العاده اليوميه
التي تؤمن بانها سبب نجاحك نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
يومي راح يكون حلو احكي ويا والدتي
بالتليفون اخابره اعز صديقه عندي مثلا
اعزم صديقاتي اقول لهم اني عازمتكم اليوم
على ترويقه يعني هي صباحيه او فتشي عمليه
مبنيه عنا نجاح وانت تخلق النجاح من ايدك
يعني يعني يوم سلبي اذا تريد تسوي يوم
سلبي انت انت اي شغله تفكر بيها اكثر من
مره راح يطلع يومك كله سلبي
[موسيقى]
اقعد اتصور احب نشاط بحيويه مبتسم اروح
للدوام وباهس دائما اقعد الصبح ابحث عن
الناس الفقره على مود اساعدهم على مود
يصير يومي جميل احلى صباح مع الشعب
العراقي ويسمع القران واحد ويسمع فيروز
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات